putin rails against cancer culture and
suggests teaching gender fluidity to
kids is a crime against humanity this is
an insider story
he took aim at cancer culture and
supported the transgender right
suggesting that teaching kids teaching
gender fluidity is a crime against
humanity while stating that russia
should remain at spiritual values and
historical traditions putin said that
some westerners believe the aggressive
deletion of whole pages of their own
history reverse discrimination against
the majority in the interest of
minorities constitute movement toward
public renewal
let me read that one more time what a
technical statement tongue twister
listen to this putin said that some
westerners believe the aggressive
deletion
of whole pages of their own history
reverse discrimination against the
majority in the interests of minorities
constitute movement towards public
renewal
wow the russian leader whose opponents
have often ended up dead or imprisoned
likened canceled culture
to reverse racism he said the
emphasizing of the racial topic divides
people
um i'll go to you first and you know
what you have to say about what putin
just said right now
uh well you know how anthony fauci was
voted uh
sexiest man alive i think putin's one
sexiest man alive in russia for like the
last 20 years in a row shirtless bear
picture yeah so um
as much as i
have
i'm not a fan of putin to put it in his
language he does have a point here
so uh look he's talking about ultimate
machismo why do you think he's elected
sexiest man alive in russia it's not
because he's actually that good looking
because he gives off that i protect the
country i take care of you and there's a
lot of people that actually empathize
with that i assume that's why your
family loves them so much um but what's
putin's motivation
like if you like forget about this whole
thing putin wants to empower russia and
so discord the united states or in the
eu or nato he's not a friend of america
he's not a friend of us so anything that
comes out of his mouth i'm thinking
what's in it for him
so i think he's just looking to uh so
discord in the united states he's not a
friend to america i think we are so wait
so you're saying he's saying this while
indirectly supporting canceled culture
thinking it's a good thing it's a good
thing i i i anything like you're talking
about former kgb anything he does i'm
not just going to take on the surface
like that's a good point thanks vlad
no there's there's something else okay
so please
please indulge us and let's go check
that out your conspiracy land so is it
conspiracy so let's let's play vladimir
putin
seven minutes we got seven minutes
before dream team call let's talk about
that so tell us what could he be
thinking
to tell americans to be very careful
with this concept of destroying and
deleting history that you had in the
past to discriminate against minorities
who are
feeling offended today
towards public renewal yeah
what's the strategy do you think putin
wants good things or bad things to
happen in america
i i think for putin and i'm being
serious with you i think for putin
uh
he is a guy that's so confident in his
abilities to lead
that and when he sits against anybody
he doesn't think anybody is at his level
because the way their government is
formatted it's set up in a way that he
doesn't have competition versus he looks
at countries like america naive because
they actually think the person you vote
for president actually runs the country
he thinks this system is ludicrous
that's what i think of putin he controls
all the levers there that's what i'm
trying to say so i don't think putin's
sister wants to destroy america i just
think he looks at americans and he
thinks you guys are so nice that's how
he looks at america well you don't he
definitely doesn't want good things to
happen in america he doesn't want
america to be involved but he doesn't
want us to all get along
but i actually think i actually think
at the same time i don't think
all advice he gives is manipulative i
don't think all answers he gives is
manipulative i don't because go flip it
flip it and say so go to russia imagine
you're living in russia okay you
officially became russian overnight
40 years you've lived in russia okay
what do you think about trump
what do you think about biden what do
you think about america do you think
every word that comes out of trump's
mouth is to hurt russia do you think
every word that comes out of biden's
mouth has to hurt russia do you think
every word that comes out of obama's
mouth bush's mouth reagan's mouth is to
hurt russia do you think that's what
every president from america is thinking
if you're russian yes
every word no okay so i don't think this
is one of those situations i think he's
concerned
that this
they may try to like make this a normal
thing in his state as well and he's like
listen pump your brakes we're not going
to play this you think he's just
speaking
on behalf of a man's man right now
he's just trying to be a man's man this
is what i i think he's really giving
good counsel that's not going to be
taken and i think that he's saying this
knowing that and that that in that way
he's kind of looking down at it saying
like oh these guys what are they what
are they doing like look at look at them
they're they're just playing this out
and it's not going to be good so no i uh
what are norwegians thinks about
vladimir putin mean he's your neighbor
norway is the only nato country that
borders to russia yes that's why
interestingly enough uh no i think
there's with um with russia there's
no i haven't been in norway in a while
but uh from my understanding it's it's a
interesting relationship it's somewhat
stable uh they do have they've had like
some military exercises but then
they typically do that whenever nato has
military exercise as well in norway so
it's kind of a it's like a an
ice relationship kind of you used a
really good analogy one time about putin
because
look they're the largest country on the
on earth are they not
russia land lands
yes yes i don't think they're a top ten
economy i'm not even sure if they're a
top 20 economy at this point it seems
like
putin is playing with like a pair of
sixes
while you know the united states has a
full house and he's still trying to like
figure out how to win that hand of poker
and he's uh he's trying to stack the
deck any way he can okay but i do think
one last thing here at least uh i do
think that
for him he needs help he's
11. somewhat stable america i don't
think he's trying to strengthen america
but i don't think he wants america to
crumble and be the next afghanistan like
because you need because america to some
extent brings law and order to the world
for better or worse and you think putin
wants that i think he wants i think he i
think chaos no i don't think so because
i think that's just it's just so
unstable at that point i don't think
that's what he's trying to go for i
think he's got nukes he'll figure it out
yeah he's ready for war at any point i
think he and g are in a bit of a
relationship and g is going to say the
same thing that vladimir putin is and i
i would argue that all of a lot of the
things that we're facing now have come
from
countries like
russia and china there's videos that go
back several years of ex-kgb spies come
out and say you know the greatest thing
you can do to america's ideological
subversion china's put almost a billion
dollars into american universities i
mean they're trying to sow discord
within the united states the way you win
the war and never fire a shot right so i
think you're right i think they want
chaos and i think he's trying to stand
tall put the brakes on and say this
isn't going to happen here in russia i
think gee would say the same thing and i
think yeah i agree i don't think he's
going to let that happen in russia but i
think it's something that people in
america ought to pay attention to
because there's a lot of credence to
what he's saying unpack the statement
what part of his statement is not
actually true
unpack the statement what he said
on history
on the surface yes yeah on the surface
the statement i'm just judging this i
agree motives of course is to protect i
always think
can we can we do chappelle in three
minutes sure okay so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]